so in this video I want to talk about
another reason why a person could
actually feel more nauseous bloated or
irritable when they consume certain
vegetables okay and that is because of
something called lectins okay lectins
are a natural insecticide that a plant
has to protect against insects and pests
a certain percentage of the population
is sensitive to lectins and when they
consume lectins in certain foods they
get more inflammation bloating nausea
etc in this video we're discuss the
vegetables that are high in lectins and
the vegetables that are low in lectins
all right now even though this is not a
vegetable
kidney beans are very very high in
lectins just FYI you never want to
consume raw kidney beans you want to
definitely pressure cook them but I
don't even recommend consuming them at
all because if you've been watching my
videos you're on ki tail okay so we
don't do beans tomato okay hi any of the
night shades are high that would be
peppers eggplant potato tomato cucumbers
now if you like cucumber is what you can
do you can consume them just peel the
outer skin off them and consume them
that way
and that way it'll lower your amounts
peas sugar snap peas as well green beans
chickpea okay and then includes hummus
all right so of course if you watch my
videos you're not gonna be doing so
anyway tofu zucchini and of course I
already mentioned in my chase these are
the vegetables that have the most
lectins now there's other ones but we're
just going to focus on the ones that
have the highest amounts this category
of vegetables have the lowest amount of
lectins okay the cruciferous vegetables
that would be arugula broccoli kale
brussel sprouts cabbage okay celery
carrot onion beet asparagus garlic leafy
greens romaine lettuce
but of course spinach has the oxalate so
you have to be careful with that if
you're sensitive parsley
stay weed and mushrooms okay so if you
suspect that you might be sensitive go
ahead and make the switch focus on
consuming these and see if your symptoms
go away all right thanks for watching so
if you want more knowledge on how to
create a healthy body subscribe now and
get daily notifications daily
notifications that sounds weird well
I'll just remind you on a daily basis
how about that